هذا وقد اظهر استطلاع اجرته صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه ان
57 بال من الامريكيين لا يوافقون على
طريقه تعامل الرئيس بايدن مع الصراع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني وكشف الاستطلاع ان
الامريكيين الاصغر سنا هم اشد انتقادا
لسلوك اسرائيل ورده فعل اداره بايد ازاء
الحرب على غزه كما اظهر ان
من الامريكيين يعتقدون بضروره وقف اسرائيل
حربها وذلك مقابل
39% يرون عكس ذلك وفي فئه الشباب اظهر
الاستطلاع ان
46% يميلون الى التعاطف اكثر مع
الفلسطينيين مقابل
27% يؤيدون
اسرائيل وكانت واشنطن بوست قد نقلت عن
مصادر مطلعه نقلت ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وجه كلمات صارمه لم لمساعديه وحسب
هذه المصادر فان بايدن قال لمساعديه ان
ارقامه في استطلاعات الراي منخفضه بشكل
غير مقبول وانه اراد ان يعرف كيف يتصرف
فريقه وحملته حيال هذا الامر واوضحت هذه
المصادر ان بايدن ابلغ كبار م يه خلال
اجتماعه بهم في البيت الابيض في الليله
التي سبقت عيد الشكر ان المؤشرات
الاقتصاديه في بلاده اظهرت اداء غير مرض
رغم ارتفاع معدل النمو وانخفاض معدلات
البطاله وحسب المصادر ذاتها فان الرئيس
بايدن وعقيلته لطالما عبر عن شكواه ما
خلال الاسابيع الاخيره من عدم احراز اي
تقدم لتقليص الفارق بينه وبين منافس
المحتمل في انتخابات الرئاسه دونالد ترامب
وان بايدن عقد اجتماعات دوريه مع مساعديه
لبحث خطط تنفيذ هذا الهدف وقالت هذه
المصادر ايضا ان بايدن ابلغ مساعيه خلال
الاجتماع الذي سبق عيد الشكر ان
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله اكبر
منه وتنضم الينا من البيت الابيض مراسله
الجزيره وجد اهلا بك وجد وجد خلاصه كل هذه
الاستطلاعات ان شعبيه الرئيس جو بايدن في
نزول وانخفاض
وتهاون في نزول وانخفاض وكذلك خديجه شعبيه
ترامب بالمقابل الذي يرجح ان يكون مرشح
الجمهوريين في ارتفاع في استطلاع الراي
لنيويورك تايمز للمره الاولى ترامب يتفوق
على الرئيس بايدن لدى فئه الشباب العمريه
من 18 حتى 29 عاما هذه هي المره الاولى
والفارق كبير كان بايدن العام الماضي
يتفوق على ترامب لدى فئه الشباب ب 21 نقطه
وحتى جولاي الماضي كان بايدن يتفوق على
ترامب لدى فئه الشباب بعشر نقاط اليوم
ترامب يتفوق على بايدن بسته نقاط وبحسب
النيويورك تايمز السبب في هذا التحول
الكبير هو طبعا طريقه اداره هذه الحرب
لدعمها لاسرائيل او اداره هذه الاداره
الامريكيه للحرب اسرائيل على غزه هذه
الحرب حقيقه اضرت كثيرا ليس فقط بالرئيس
بايدن بل ايضا
بالحزب الديمقراطي امس عدد من المشرعين
الديمقراطيين البارزين بعثوا رساله الى
الرئيس الامريكي يناشدون بدفع اسرائيل على
تغيير نهجها في في غزه فئه الشباب
الامريكي حقيقه هم لا لا يرون بان اسرائيل
معنيه بخفض عدد الخسائر البشريه في غزه
وليست معنيه بالسلام كما
انها كما انهم يريدون لهذه الحرب ان تتوقف
الان حتى لو كان هذا الامر يعني بقاء حماس
في السلطه في في غزه هناك تململ كبير لدى
الشارع الامريكي من هذه الحرب خديجه بيو
في الثامن من ديسمبر مركز بيو للابحاث
اجرس استطلاعا للراي اظهر ايضا ان فقط ثلث
الامريكيين يؤيد اداء بايدن في هذه الحرب
حقيقه تراجع كبير يؤرق الرئيس بايدن وان
كان لا يريد ان يتحدث عنه في العلن سئل
اول امس من قبل الصحفيين كيف تبرر هذا
التراجع الكبير الى ادنى مستويات ومستويات
قياسيه لشعبيته قال بايدن انتم تقراون
الاستطلاعات الخاطئه بعدها بيوم اي امس
واشنطن بوست اصدرت مقاله جمعت فيها 17
استطلاعا للراي جرى في الولايات المتحده
لنسب تاييد الرئيس بايدن وذكرت الواشنطن
بوست ان معدل تاييد بايدن في جميع
استطلاعات الراي هو فقط
38% اي قريب جدا من نسبه ان ثلثي
الامريكيين ضد نهج بايدن مع اسرائيل
وتاييده عمه مع اسرائيل حتى بعد ان غيرت
الاداره الامريكيه قليلا من لهجتها بان
بدات بمناشى اسرائيل بتجنب قصف المدنيين
لم تتغير نسب الاستطلاع هذه لم تتغير نسب
عدم الرضا عن اداء الرئيس بايدن مع فيما
يتعلق باسرائيل ما يعني انه بالنسبه
للناخب الامريكي خديجه حقيقه الامر الذي
يهم ليس الكلمات العلنيه للمسؤولين هنا بل
ما يحدث على الارض في غزه شكرا جزيلا لك
وجد وقفي من البيت الابيض